the sequel to the hangover big shoes to
fill
I canna lie that's tough the hangover 2
alright so two years ago a movie came
out became a smash hit and has gone down
is like one of the greatest comedies of
all time or whatever and it was really
funny so of course there's gonna be a
sequel because it's not about
practicality or what makes sense it's
all about the money so now we have the
hangover 2 and so the nard dog from the
office is marrying one of the hot chicks
from Sucker Punch and they all go to
Thailand for the wedding then blackout
and hangover 2 and right off the bat I
know you're asking is it as funny as the
first one
no it's not the bummer about this movie
is that it doesn't make sense that it
would happen again I mean you have the
same people in the same kind of scenario
really feels recycled I'm sure the
mindset was if it ain't broke don't fix
it so we'll do everything the same as we
did in the first one and they do they
really do never see a movie where it's
like what are the odds that that same
thing what happened to the same person
again this movies like the definition of
that I think it's a phrase that should
be coined whenever a sequel does that
now it should be called they hang over
to that movie some situational scenarios
are different but ultimately it's like
the same thing like in the first one
someone loses a tooth and this one
someone loses something else another
body part so the same kind of parallel
and it would have been kind of
interesting if they even incorporated
that one guy from the first one you know
the one who was missing but they didn't
again he misses out on this whole thing
I was watching the movie guardians it's
kind of funny it's interesting and then
I thought to myself like inner monologue
style like JD from scrubs or some [ __ ] I
do that I thought yeah but how many
times have you laughed in this movie I
think it was actually twice yeah it's
kind of like you know the alternate
dimension in fringe how things are
similar but kind of different like
instead of Green Lantern they have Red
Lantern that's what the hangover 2 is
hangover 2 is like The Hangover if it
were released in the alternate dimension
in Fringe 98% of the movies the same
some things are tweaked for situational
differences but ultimately it's like a
parallel of the first one but when they
do it it's in a way that's not as good
there it is right there the first one
was just a lot more fun you know going
wild in Vegas you're watching the movie
going that would be awesome if that
happen to me worst case scenario you get
Heather Graham but in the hangover 2
they're in Bangkok you're watching it
and you're like the place looks just
sweaty and dirty and smoggy and
overpopulated and there's a bunch of
crime that they have to go through so
you're just watching the movie going I
if that ever happens to me - [ __ ] that
it kind of
goes against what hangover was all about
hangover one was like the bachelor party
movie of your dreams this movies like
the bachelor brunch of your nightmares
it was not dog [ __ ] but I will say it's
alright but you won't remember it in
t-minus 15 minutes in this one just the
jokes and the shenanigans are darker and
they're less funny this was clearly a
studio call I have to believe that the
director was like there's no way to make
a sequel fit and the studio's like yeah
but the first one made a lot of money so
you're going to make a sequel trust us
on this so this is the weekend of
sequels that got my review of Kung Fu
Panda 2 coming up pretty soon or might
be up now depending on when you see this
and if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more